royal highness um do you have any
wishes for your new niece a little bit
oh i wish her all the very best i can't
wait to meet her
kate middleton is excited to meet her
new niece
it's magic it's pretty amazing exactly
one week after meghan markle and prince
harry welcomed
their second child together lily diana
mount that in windsor
the duchess of cambridge is speaking out
in public for the first time
i can't wait to meet her while the 39
year old royal paid a visit to a school
in the united kingdom
attendees were also curious whether kate
had met lily in real life or virtually
because we haven't yet um yet met her
yet so hopefully
that will be soon
and even though she has yet to meet her
new niece kate and husband prince
william were among the first to share a
statement on their joint instagram
account
congratulating megan harry on their new
bundle of joy
it's a big deal of course there's been
tension in the royal family
ever since megan and harry stepped down
as senior members of the royal family in
january 2020
and following their march 2021 tell-all
interview with oprah winfrey
but royal expert katie nichol tells e.t
that the royal family is hopeful that
baby lily
can heal their rift this family
division has really gone on for a very
long time now it's well over a year
it's been many many months since charles
the queen indeed the cambridges have
seen archie
in the flesh and we know that there have
been some
really quite deep problems between harry
and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together but kate isn't the only
royal to speak publicly about baby lily
earlier this week carrie's father prince
charles recently spoke publicly about
his new granddaughter
for the first time too while visiting
the bmw
mini factory in oxford england the
development of technology like electric
vehicles
or green hydrogen for that matter for
heavy transport
is vital for maintaining the health of
our world
for future generations something i'm
only
too aware of today having recently
become a grandfather for the fifth time
and such happy news really does remind
while of the necessity of continued
innovation
in this area especially around
sustainable battery technology in view
of the legacy we bequeath to our
grandchildren but what about the queen
well when megan harry's daughter was
born a source told e.t that she was the
first one they called
adding that her royal majesty met their
baby girl over video call
everything was just perfect and we know
that lily bette was named after her
grandmother's childhood nickname
harry did seek his grandmother's
blessing to use
the name lily bed for their daughter he
did speak to her about it
and the family were all notified ahead
of the birth that harry did have that
conversation
i understand with his grandmother to
make sure that
he had her blessing in the naming of
their daughter but back to kate
it's a huge honor to welcome her the
united kingdom the royal teamed up with
first lady dr
jill biden and visited conor downs
academy in hale england
like always the ladies dressed to
impress kate was effortless in a red
ensemble
and jill wore a white dress with a
bright pink blazer
the women were busy chatting with
children visiting classrooms
and hanging out in the farm area of the
school i met some wonderful
teachers and principals and
and most of all the children who were so
inspiring and so well behaved
the dynamic duo also led a round table
discussion
on the importance of early childhood on
lifelong outcomes
the visit took place during the first
day of the g7 summit which is being held
across
this weekend in cornwall thank you so
much that's very exciting
thank you for having us jill and her
husband president joe biden are in
england to meet with the royals and will
join queen elizabeth and prince charles
on friday evening for a special
reception